choisir c'est renault
c'est par ces mots andré gide sous
l'important
valeur morale de nos choix j'en ai fait
l'expérience très récemment lorsque j'ai
souhaité offrir à mon frère pour noël un
cadeau comme c'était facile j'ai utilisé
internet une plate forme de
recommandations bien connu du e-commerce
qui commence par un a et qui finit par
ma zone kim offre donc la possibilité en
quelques questions de trouver le cadeau
idéal c'est facile ça va vite c'est
ludique
la première question est ce que mon
frère est un homme ou une femme
c'est un homme avant la deuxième
question c'est des univers de cadeaux
qui sont proposés les vêtements le
cinéma la musique le rasage le rasage
intéressant et là la magie d'internet
fait que tout d'un coup j'ai liste de
cadeaux structuré par ordre de
pertinence
vous savez on a l'habitude depuis un
certain nombre d'années qu'on utilise
internet et des moteurs de recherche
les trois premières réponses sont
souvent les plus pertinentes et là en
effet il y à une corde pertinence et le
premier cadeau à ceux ci deux qualités
fondamentales semble-t-il pour le met le
nombre de fois où il a été vendu et le
taux de recommandation le plus élevé
donc les yeux fermés bien entendu par
habitude je sélectionne ce cadeau je
paye avec mastercard et je deviens leur
propriétaire d'une boîte de 100 string
épilation pour femmes
mais comment on en est arrivé là
j'étais bien sur internet expliqué je
cherchais un cadeau pour mon frère et je
me retrouve avec une boîte de cadeaux
enfin de stream dont la quelle est la
valeur morale qu'est ce qui va dire
quand je vais lui offrir
à moins peut-être internet sage des
choses sur mon frère que je ne sais pas
encore parce que internet c'est un peu
ça le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
que on fait des outils big data qui font
des grands calculs mais ils font que des
calculs ils ne comprennent pas le sens
de la donner et pour comprendre le sens
de la donner c'est très compliqué
l'humain peut le faire mais une
intelligence artificielle elles peinent
un peu
c'est ce qu'a vécu microsoft comme mes
aventures très récemment lorsque il a
développé une intelligence artificielle
sous la forme d'un agent conversationnel
sur twitter qu'ils étaient capables de
comprendre les échanges les
conversations et c est petit à petit en
ce programme en de se forger une opinion
au bout de huit heures son opinion était
fait il exprimé de vive voix que la
politique d'un adolf hitler était
vraiment très bien microsoft l'a vite
retirée et on voit bien que aujourd'hui
un un problème de sens la représentation
du sens la compréhension tout le monde
parle de de ces intelligences
artificielles meilleur que l'uma elles
comprennent rien on va l'expliquer l'un
des problèmes aujourd'hui c'est donc de
trouver une donnée qualifiée vrai dont
la valeur et la véracité sont clairement
prouvé pour ça l'innovation n'est pas
avare on a inventé le blog chaîne ce
tiers de confiance vous savez cet
organisme qui est capable de vous
fournir une donnée qualifiée
contextualiser qui vous assure que cette
donnée a livré donc pour mieux vous
connaître
parce que c'est un peu ça les outils
d'internet ils veulent faire votre
connaissance et bien
des grosses sociétés comme google se
sont associés avec des tiers de
confiance le premier mastercard ainsi il
est capable de connaître tous s'y
présente vos activités financières vos
dépenses en ligne sur le net mais aussi
quand vous le faites dans la vraie vie
hors ligne vous riez plus haut rassurez
vous il ya d'autres tiers de confiance
il paraît que google s'est aussi
associée à des constructeurs automobiles
français renault et maintenant dans les
futurs véhicules on peut penser que on
aura le système android le système
d'exploitation de google qui pourra en
toute indulgence monitorer votre qualité
de conduite vérifier où vous allez
si c'est bien en cohérence avec vos
dépenses mais entendu écouté la radio
que vous écoutez savoir la musique que
vous préférez et peut-être même
comprendre les conversations vous avez
avec vos passagers ça fait peur
moi ça m'inquiète parce que depuis que
j'ai vécu cette aventure de trouver un
cadeau pour mon frère ma boite mail se
remplit de propositions d'achat sur des
produits d'hygiène féminine
j'en viens à douter de moi même le
problème qu'on a avec ses outils
cette intelligence artificielle c'est
pas du tout qu'elle soit plus
intelligente que nous le problème de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
qu'elle va se former en apprenant de la
société qu'elle étudie pour pouvoir
former une intelligence artificielle à
reconnaître des chats il suffit de lui
montrer soixante mille fois parce que
les lentes à la détente
une photo de chat enfin pas la même à
chaque fois que sinon et à chaque fois
on lui dit ben tu vois ça c'est un chat
ça c'est un chat ça c'est un chat au
bout d'un moment elle comprend ce qui
inquiète dans l'intelligence
artificielle c'est en fait le miroir
qu'elle nous tend le miroir où on n'ose
pas regarder ce que ce que l'on est
parce que parfois c'est souvent une
image un peu déformés et inquiétante
parce que souvent elle est liée à une
société bien particulière et
l'intelligence artificielle et les
globalisé elle peut s'adapter à d'autres
sociétés s'adapter ou s'imposer je vais
vous donner un exemple tout bête
on parle aujourd'hui d'un truc
formidable génial les véhicules autonome
vous savez ces véhicules qui se
conduisent tout seul aujourd'hui
beaucoup se plaignent qu'il n'ya qu'une
personne dans un véhicule alors qu'il ya
quatre places demain il y aura personne
dans le véhicule
l'inquiétude qu'il ya aujourd'hui dans
la programmation de l'intelligence de
ses véhicules
c'est lorsqu'il ya un risque d'accident
rend bien sûr c'est pas possible
les ingénieurs qui ont conçu sa ont paré
à toute éventualité mais il ya tellement
d'humains tellement de situations
compliquées donc au cas où une voiture à
un moment donné malheureusement elle est
autonome
elle est dans un accident qui va
provenir elle le sent elle le prédit
mais elle peut pas l'éviter elle peut
pas éviter la perte d'une vie humaine
mais comment on fait pour la programmer
ou et le choix car choisir c'est
renoncer
le problème du choix ici mais il est
simple je peux pas laisser par exemple à
dijon une voiture intelligente qui doit
ce programme est tout seul dans les rues
en lui disant ah non il fallait pas
l'écraser
ah non il fallait pas l'écraser soixante
mille fois
donc il faut trouver d'autres chemins le
m haïti qui est un organisme de
recherche et d'enseignement dans le
domaine des technologies aux états unis
à trouver une solution a essayé de
trouver une solution
il a recréé les situations
potentiellement une voiture un véhicule
autonome dans le cas d'un risque où il
ça peut entraîner la mort mais il faut
faut stimuler le choix et elle a demandé
à des internautes souvent des
internautes américains des étudiants de
se connecter et puis de prendre la
décision pour la voiture
heureusement il ya de résultats le
premier il a accepté par toutes les
sociétés dans le monde
la première chose à faire c'est d'éviter
d'écraser les enfants la deuxième elle
me rappelle l'adage que j'ai entendu un
jour provenant d'un américain qui me dit
aux états unis pour échapper à un ours
il faut courir plus vite que son voisin
là le véhicule autonome en fait
et bien c'est simple on va lui donner le
choix d' écraser la personne qui a la
valeur morale la plus faible
donc on peut imaginer bientôt que nour
on pourra télécharger une nouvelle
application qui en fin de soirée
lorsqu'on veut rentrer à pied pour
éviter le risque d'un dérapage d'un
véhicule autonome qui se promène dans
les rues
on va en réalité augmentée passer le
téléphone surtout au visage et savoir
que je peux rentrer avec vous parce que
vous avez une valeur normale un peu
inférieure à la mienne
bon bien entendu moi qui maintenant est
fiché par une intelligence artificielle
comme achetant des strings pour femmes
je vais avoir beaucoup d'amis parce que
vous voulez tous rentrés avec moi au cas
où il ya quelque chose qui arrive
bon c'est une situation un peu ubuesque
un bien entendu mais elle a pour
objectif d'attirer votre attention pour
résoudre ces problèmes il ya des actions
qui sont menées en europe il ya des
droits qui sont chaque jour imposé pour
faire respecter en fait nos sociétés
très récemment c'est le droit d'auteur
sur internet parce qu'on diffuse
facilement des choses qui ne sont pas
forcément fait par nous mais il ya aussi
le rg [ __ ] ce truc qui semble un peu
contraignant mais en fait qui est là
pour nous protéger c'est le règlement
général de la protection de nos données
personnelles
la voix est une donnée personnelle et ça
c'est important de le comprendre c'est
que les données personnelles c'est pas
que votre nom prénom ou votre compte
bancaire
c'est beaucoup de choses et avec ces
informations on peut savoir beaucoup de
choses de vous des connaissances
implicite parfois même croire qu on vous
connaît mieux que ce que vous ne vous
connaissez au niveau du gouvernement
français depuis des années il ya des
investissements force que dans les
nouvelles technologies on le voit avec
le développement de la french tech et
très récemment avec des investissements
massifs dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle certains
diront que c'est trop tard
mais non en fait il faut savoir prendre
son temps dans ces domaines parce que ce
ne sont pas des domaines technologiques
c'est des domaines sociétaux et nous
avons une société qui est basée sur une
histoire qui est basé sur des choix et
il faut savoir à quoi nous allons
renoncer
donc il faut construire des réponses qui
sont adaptés à notre histoire à nos
sociétés au niveau territorial si
l'université de bourgogne franche comté
va donner naissance à un laboratoire de
connaissances et d'intelligence
artificielle distribué où on va
développer des intelligences
artificielles explicables et éthiques
mais le plus important c'est le graal
plus un c'est vous c'est nous c'est nous
tous
c'est cet individu qui a tellement pris
l'habitude de brader ses données
personnelles pour le prix d'un coup qui
en plus qui se mange pas pour un
bourguignon c'est un comble il faut
vraiment être attentif et prendre
conscience maintenant qu'à chaque choix
que vous ferez sur internet parce que ça
va vite c'est amusant et puis on a pris
l'habitude à chaque fois on prend le
risque de renoncer à nos valeurs morales
je vous remercie